It is known as the rainbow nation for its
cultural, linguistic and religious diversity.
It’s constitution alone acknowledges 11
different languages!
Yes, this is South Africa, a country situated
in the extreme south of Africa.
This is not a small country, its surface is
larger than Germany, France, Italy, Belgium
and the Netherlands combined!
It is, by far, the most developed economy
of all the countries situated south of the
Sahara desert.
In the year 2010, it was the first African
country to hold a Soccer World Championship.
The summer of Shakira´s “Waka Waka” if
anyone cares to remember that...
The most important month in South Africa’s
History was April 1994.
Between the 26th and 29th of that month, South
Africa celebrated the first, free, universal,
and democratic elections.
They were also the longest because the elections
last for 4 long days.
During that time, South Africans left their
houses massively to vote... having to wait
in queues kilometers long!
The hype was justified, for these elections
meant the end of 300 years of colonialism
and white supremacy.
The elections marked the end of apartheid.
APARTHEID
Apartheid was a system based on racial segregation
which remained in effect for 50 years.
It mainly consisted of separating the white
population from the black population.
This applied in any situation: living, studying,
even the spending of leisure time.
Obviously, as you might imagine, all the best
areas and services were built for, and used
by, the white population.
A good example were ambulances.
Even though the black population were 80%
of the total population, the barely had any
ambulances to use.
However, the ambulances for the white population
were numerous and, also, refused to carry
black people because they couldn’t according
to the law.
Apartheid gave the white population all the
political power and, also, established many
limitations, precisely, in order to consolidate
white power.
As an example, mixed race relationships and
marriage were completely forbidden.
Quite simply, It left the black population
in an inhuman situation.
It could be said there were two different
South Africa's, one black and terribly poor,
and the other, white, and very wealthy.
And of course, those who rebelled suffered
terrible punishments and repression...
MANDELA´S DREAM
But that
all changed in 1994 thanks to Nelson Mandela,
also known as Madiba.
He was considered the father of the country.
Mandela lead the political fight against Apartheid
and racism, but he had to pay for it.
In 1961 he was sentenced to life imprisonment
for betrayal.
Mandela spent 27 years in jail, until 1992.
Nevertheless, two years later in the 1994
elections were held and he was elected as
President of South Africa, the first black
president in the country's history.
Many were surprised to see Mandela aiming
for reconciliation rather than revenge.
Mandela dreamt of a free, united, and prosperous
South Africa.
He made it clear in his inaugural speech:
We have triumphed in the effort to implant
hope in the breasts of the millions of our
people.
We enter into a covenant that we shall build
the society in which all South Africans, both
black and white, will be able to walk tall,
without any fear in their hearts, assured
of their inalienable right to human dignity
- a rainbow nation at peace with itself and
the world.
Mandela kept his word.
He worked towards a united South Africa, and
when the time came, he left power following
the limits of the constitution.
This all turned him into a legend for the
country.
But let’s now focus on present-day South
Africa.
It is the only country in the world to hold
three capital cities: Cape Town, the capital
city for legislative power, Pretoria, for
executive power, and Bloemfontein, the judicial
capital city.
And on top of that, neither is the the most
populated or the one where most businesses
concentrate…
For that we have to move to a fourth city:
Johannesburg.
It’s not uncommon for different textbooks
to state different cities as the capital of
South Africa.
Now, after the fall of Apartheid, South Africa
experienced quite an economic boost.
Since 1994, the economy, considering purchasing
power, has tripled.
Poverty has been strongly reduced and hundreds
of thousands of black families make it into
the middle class every year.
And even though violence is still high (it
needs to be said that South Africa is quite
a violent country) it has also reduced.
Further, in general, the access to drinkable
water, electricity and health care has also
improved quite a lot.
To illustrate the situation: South Africa
is the biggest tourist center and financial
power in the south of the continent.
Its stock market is the most important in
Africa and it is, also, an important place
for the automotive industry.
Companies such as BMW and General Motors have
factories here.
So it all sounds pretty good, right?
Well, things today are actually not looking
that rosy.
CRISIS AND STAGNATION
Despite its numerous achievements, the economy
hasn’t changed since 2009.
The economy isn’t growing, unemployment
rates are one of the highest in the world
and, in general, very few people are working.
The country has a population of about 55 million
people, 15 million are without work, and many
of these jobs that people do have are informal.
And this is not the only problem.
Investment by companies has also kept decreasing
in the last 9 years.
Its currency, the RAND, has been greatly depreciated
and public debt is about to be declared as
"junk bonds".
This is a pretty major economic disaster.
In fact, in the last years, people with money
are escaping the country.
So what happened in South Africa?
What lead to this crisis?
JACOB ZUMA
This is Jacob Zuma, the president since 2009,
and his years in office have been, well, they’ve
been a huge mess.
The man is facing 783 corruption cases.
He been described as a professional at taking
things that are not his.
But this is not the only issue.
Mr. Zuma´s political decisions don’t encourage
foreign investment.
Further, the President's labor regulations
are an obstacle when it comes to job creation.
And the regulations are getting more and more
rigid.
His last idea was a huge raise in minimum
wage.
Something that doesn’t make a bunch of sense
in a country where there are so few people
working.
In fact, many financial analysts have criticized
the measure by saying it is nonsensical to
establish a minimum wage which amounts to
twice as much as half of the workers are making.
Now, let’s be honest, we all want our salaries
to raise, but to do so we´ll need to create
wealth first, don't you think?
If job creation was already an issue before,
imagine what’s going to happen now with
higher salaries.
South Africa has other problems too.
An important one is its problematic education
system...
AN AWFUL EDUCATION SYSTEM
The education system in South Africa is pretty
awful:
Picture this: 1 in every 3 students who has
attended school for 6 years has difficulties
when it comes to something as essential as
reading, and only 1 in every 100 black students
gets an engineering diploma.
We can now understand the reason why national
companies complain about the difficulty to
find skilled labour.
And it is not a money issue.
South Africa is one of the countries with
a highest investment in education in the world.
So, what’s happening?
According to some people, the ones to blame
are the Democratic Teachers´ Union.
They control the state education system and
it has become a real mafia.
The Union is an ally of President Zuma.
Zuma, besides putting an end to education
supervision, he has pulled so many strings
get more teachers that the education level
of teachers themselves is very low.
A few years ago, maths teachers in the country
were given a test (these were teachers teaching
maths to 11 and 12 year-olds.)
The result?
8 out of 10 of these teachers got lower results
than the the results expected of their students.
And to be honest, maths isn’t exactly of
the President´s strengths...
Obviously, the results in white students,
who go to private schools, are far better.
Showing that maybe some of that apartheid
heritage is still in effect…
If these problems weren’t bad enough, racial
conflict in South Africa has been growing
in the last few years.
The Economic Freedom Fighters is a radical
political party founded in 2013.
This party is now the third largest political
force in the country.
Some if its members are suggesting to almost
invert Apartheid and apply it to the white
population.
It is still a minority party but as an element
of subversion it works quite well.
Anyway, it looks like Mandela's dream is now
in danger.
So, what do you think?
Will South Africa make Madiba´s dreams come
true?
Will South Africa become the most prosperous
nation in Africa again?
Or will hatred, distrust, and bad politics
triumph?
Let us know in the comments below.
Also, if you liked this video, be sure to
click that like button below and don’t forget
to subscribe, we put out brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
And as always, I’ll see you next time.